kann ich ihnen helfen kann ich ihnen
helfen ja gern mein sohn braucht eine
hose ja gern mein sohn braucht eine hose
welche größe hat er denn welche größe
hat er denn er hat größe 31 er hat größe
31 schau mal die hose steht dir sicher
gut
schau mal die hose steht dir sicher gut
ich weiß nicht wo kann ich die hose
anprobieren
die umkleidekabinen sind dort hinten
links die umkleidekabinen sind dort
hinten links die hose sieht sehr schön
aus
die hose sieht sehr schön aus
das finde ich auch sie steht ihm
ausgezeichnet
das finde ich auch
sie steht ihm ausgezeichnet
nein die hose gefällt mir gar nicht
sie ist hässlich und absolut uncool
sie passt mir auch nicht
sie passt mir auch nicht sie ist viel zu
weit
sie ist viel zu weit
wie gefallen dir die schuhe wie gefallen
dir die schuhe wie gefallen ihnen die
schuhe wie gefallen ihnen die schuhe sie
gefallen mir sehr gut
sie gefallen mir sehr gut
wie kann ich dir helfen wie kann ich dir
helfen
wie kann ich ihnen helfen
sie müssen mir nicht helfen
ich schaue nur ich schaue nur
patrick wie steht mir die bluse patrick
wie steht mir die bluse sie steht ihr
sehr gut
sie steht
sehr gut toll die farbe von der bluse
passt zu deinen augen
toll die farbe von der bluse passt zu
deinen augen
gefällt dir dieses hemd gefällt dir
dieses hemd
gefällt ihnen dieses hemd gefällt ihnen
ja mir gefällt der stoff er ist sehr
angenehm
ja mir gefällt die farbe
sie passt zu meinen haaren ja mir
gefällt die farbe
sie passt zu meinen haaren nein es ist
zu kurz nein es ist zu kurz nein es ist
mir zu eng
nein es ist mir zu eng
passt dir das t shirt passt dir das t
shirt
ja es passt wie angegossen
ja es passt mir ja es passt mir nein es
passt mir nicht
nein es passt mir nicht kannst du es mir
in einer nummer größer geben kannst du
es mir in einer nummer größer geben
kannst du es mir in einer nummer kleiner
bringen kannst du es mir in einer nummer
kleiner bringen
entschuldigung wo finde ich rücke
entschuldigung wo finde ich rücke im
ersten stock bei der damenmode im ersten
stock bei der damenmode
ich suche einen anzug
da müssen sie in den zweiten stock
ich möchte ein paar film kaufen
die parfümerie ist auf diesem stockwerk
gehen sie den korridor entlang dann nach
rechts und gegenüber von dem
schmuckgeschäft ist die parfümerie
gehen sie den korridor entlang dann nach
rechts und gegenüber von dem
schmuckgeschäft ist die parfümerie
wo bist du wo bist du
ich bin im einkaufszentrum
ich suche ein geschenk für meine mutter
[Musik]
sie hat nächste woche geburtstag
was willst du ihr schenken
hast du schon eine idee was willst du
ihr schenken hast du schon eine idee ich
schenke ihr einen hut oder eine
sonnenbrille
ich schenke ihr einen hut oder eine
sie fliegt in zwei wochen auf die
malediven
malediven wo ist hier die apotheke wo
ist hier die apotheke sie ist im ersten
stock sie ist im ersten stock die finden
sie im ersten stock die finden sie im
ersten stock gehen sie in den ersten
stock gehen sie in den ersten stock
sie ist im zweiten stock sie ist im
zweiten stock gehen sie in den zweiten
stock gehen sie in den zweiten stock
ich glaube sie ist im dritten stock ich
glaube sie ist im dritten stock ich bin
mir aber nicht sicher
ich bin mir aber nicht sicher
schauen sie doch auf der
informationstafel
informationstafel tut mir leid ich weiß
es nicht tut mir leid ich weiß es nicht
entschuldigung ich kann ihnen nicht
helfen
möchtest du gratis online deutsch lernen
mehr als 200 video lektionen abonniere
unseren kanal möchtest du gratis online
deutsch lernen mehr als 200 video
lektionen abonniere unseren kanal